thousands on the streets of Baker here
in northern Gaza calling for revenge
against Israel this was a mass funeral
for three Palestinians in the early 20s
Mohamed Al Attar MC mahmoud al walid a
and mohammad abu namaz targeted by the
israeli army later on saturday night I
demand the Palestinian fighting groups
retaliate against the Israeli crimes
either in West Bank or from Gaza the
Israeli military says it used tank and
helicopter fire on the group after
spotting armed men near the border fence
it comes a week after four armed
Palestinians were killed in similar
circumstances in a month that has seen a
surge in attempts to break through the
fence Hamas and Islamic Jihad are
calling them unsanctioned individual
actions carried out by angry youth atom
fear shut out Philistine there is anger
among the Palestinian youth over Israeli
aggression and crimes including their
crimes in dealing with Palestinian
prisoners arrests and attacks on West
bankers and the siege of Gaza all
Israeli aggression created this kind of
anger among the Palestinian youth for a
second night in a row on Saturday
rockets were fired out of Gaza one of
them landing on a terrace in the Israeli
town of starett increasing insecurity
around Gaza in recent weeks as being
seen in Israel as at least in part
related to the upcoming elections in
September before the recent polls in
April there was an upsurge in rocket
fire out of Gaza seen here as a way of
trying to increase pressure on Israel at
a politically sensitive time in recent
months rocket fire as long as it
resulted in no injuries or loss of life
has typically been followed by Israeli
air strikes on evacuated bases and camps
inside Gaza these attempts to break
through the Gaza fence though are being
met immediately by deadly force there's
little doubt the temperature is getting
higher again in and around Gaza and that
the chances of another military
escalation are also on the rise Harry
Fawcett al Jazeera West Jerusalem